jack lang est ce soir l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous et bien entre une mission
internationale la dernière à la demande
du secrétaire général de l'onu porté sur
la piraterie maritime et puis entre une
critique nouvelles de votre part de
l'éducation nationale mais on n'abordera
bien d'autres questions
au cours de cette émission en trois
parties d'abord bien sûr on a envie de
vous entendre sur la situation en egypte
jack lang sur ces heures dramatiques au
lendemain d'une marche pacifique la
marche du million de manifestants
et puis on ne vous entendent également
sur la nouvelle polémique tunisienne a
autour de michèle alliot-marie certains
de vos camarades du parti socialiste
réclame sa démission
ensuite anne sophie mercier
collaboratrice des inrockuptibles du
monde magazine nous rejoindra pour
évoquer votre appartenance au parti
socialiste
enfin sonia mabrouk de public sénat sur
avec nous pour des questions plus
personnelles mais bien sûr il sera
beaucoup question de culture avec vous
d'abord l'egypte bien sûr les choses
tournent mal au lendemain de cette
manifestation
nombreuses et pacifique pour réclamer le
départ d'hosni moubarak
comment est-ce que vous réagissez à ces
scènes violentes auxquelles on a assisté
90ème violente si bien compris ce sont
des actes d'agression commis par les
personnages stipendiés qui cherchent à
semer la terreur et intimider le peuple
tunisien et égyptien pardon donc
salutaire surprenant n'a pas d'une
dictature d'un homme qui s'accroche au
pouvoir et qui ne veut pas y renoncer
mais qui cherche en effet à attiser la
peur l'inquiétude l'angoissé
voilà et sont des actes criminels qui
sont accomplis par ceux qui s'attaquent
aux au peuple égyptien moubarak est plus
qu'un dictateur selon vous ce soir après
avoir mobilisé
certains de ces nervis et une partie de
la population alors on ne sait pas
comment il l'a fait descendre dans la
rue mais elle était là où il dispose de
moyens de ressources
je peux pas je n'ai pas la réponse
exacte d'aucune manière saison était
payé et rémunéré pour commettre ces
actes d'agression nous sommes qu'en plus
certains d'entre eux sont habitués
depuis longtemps savent et dans les
commissariats l'immeuble yacoubian enfin
c'est un livre il fallu lire beaucoup en
france qui expliquait depuis très
longtemps à quel point ce régime est un
régime d'oppression de dictature de
corruption vis-à-vis duquel il ya une
immense complaisance international
certes nous barak a contribué à la
stabilité à la paix il faut le
reconnaître dans cette région du monde
en même temps c'est un régime
aujourd'hui corrompu vermoulu et et je
suis heureux vraiment heureux que le
peuple égyptien et trouver cette force
et ce courage de s'exprimer et il faut
le soutenir absolument soutenir soutenir
le peuple vous avez parlé de la
dictature mais très peu
disait que moubarak était un dictateur
jusque-là non dans les capitales
occidentales trompeuses alors après ces
événements que l'on assiste aujourd'hui
vous vous diriez que c'est pire qu'un
dictateur ne veut pas dire qu'il faut la
divination de la dictature à lavaveix
des formes diverses
mais quand même cet homme est au pouvoir
depuis très longtemps un parti dominant
sinon unique là la prison pour beaucoup
de gens parfois même des gens qui sont
de simples gens le dernier film de sf
chahine chaos équipe lui raconter bien
de quelle façon que dans la vie
quotidienne
les gens sont malmenés arrêté stipendiés
exploiter etc
c'est un régime qui a fait d'écrasement
d'écrasement des gens et au bénéfice de
quelques privilégiés
ce qui n'enlève en rien pas tout
mélanger oui à la qualité d'une certaine
politique internationale qui a été menée
par moubarak et son gouvernement
mais selon vous est-ce que l'espoir
soulevé pourrait être de courte durée
je suis pas sûr plat je ne suis pas
capable
j'espère que une solidarité à cheval
très fort ça s'organise et à kout poupe
en soutien du peuple égyptien et que
beaucoup vont s'ériger contre ceux de
ses actes de terrorisme
en attendant côté on nous dit les frères
musulmans s'ils reviennent etc
mais les actes commis par le pouvoir
sont des actes de terreur donc vous
parler d'un terroriste moubarak
si on en vous suivant les envies de
terroristes de l'utilisateur de terreur
voilà comment éviter ça un président qui
ne peut pas en régime en tout cas pas le
régime sait pas comment je ne fais pas
dire que je me connais pas mais ce
manifestement ça a été organisé
orienté préparez vous demander le départ
sans délai de moubarak je crois que tout
le monde le dit j'ai du projet entre vu
là une phrase du président de la
république réclamant que s'en servir et
sentant la transition s'opère jouera il
faut espérer il faut vraiment que la
demande internationale soit une demande
de transition rapide et pacifique
alors on le sait on l'a dit les blessés
sont très nombreux plusieurs centaines
au caire certains bailleurs atteint par
me blanchet des coups de machette des
cocktails molotov ont été également de
la cour du musée du caire jack lang est
ce que la démocratie naissante mais
aussi les trésors culturels de l'egypte
sont en danger est ce que c'est aussi
une préoccupation et vous c'est ce
serait de voir dictateur ou pas
dictateur ou pas ça le devoir de
monsieur moubarak et son régime de
protéger cet extraordinaire musée et
voilà je constate que depuis plusieurs
jours on ne prend pas de mesures assez
efficace sauf de l'intérieur pour
préserver ses richesses uniques
évidemment on le sait le trésor de
toutankhamon et tant d'autres choses
admirables quelques d'ailleurs quelques
oeuvres ont déjà été enlevées certaines
momies ont disparu alors qu'au moins ils
rendent service à l'histoire et à son
peuple en sauvant ses trésors
ces trésors qui appartiennent non
seulement à l'egypte n'est au bond
entier est ce que vous croyez en hiver
un printemps du monde arabe avec les
manifestations certaines sont annoncées
en syrie en jordanie on a vu ce qui
s'est passé en tunisie on parle de
l'algérie bien sûr entre autres pays le
yémen monde passée s'est emporté trop
mais quand même je suis heureux
un mot profondément heureux que le
peuple tunisien et ce courage
extraordinaire de s'arracher à cette
dictature et je suis confiant je suis
sûre que le peuple tunisien réussir a
conçu une démocratie
je pense que chaque fois la démocratie
peut marquer des points
c'est un progrès et j'aimerais mais ne
pas être rien prédire
j'aimerais que le mouvement est
enclenché ressemble à celui qu'on l'a
connu dans cette année sans pareil de
1989 tandis que nous célébrions ici le
bicentenaire de la révolution française
un peu partout l'étincelle de la liberté
en europe sur jc à prague
jusqu'à la roumanie et 120 sans oublier
berlin donc puis cela démocratie mais
sans violence si cela est possible
ce même souhaitable qui n'est pas de
violence puissent démocratie s'installer
dans différents pays alors je me prendre
des formes différentes ce qu'on peut pas
comparer chaque pays a son histoire
chaque pays a son système
chaque pays a son régime alors parlons
de la polémique autour de michèle alliot
marie et ses vacances au plus fort de la
crise 20 en tunisie et de la répression
au mois de décembre dernier
et puis ce vol intérieur offerte par un
de ses amis
elle s'est expliquée à l'assemblée
nationale vous étiez dans l'hémicycle
jack lang est ce que vous estimez
qu'elle devrait démissionner après cette
nouvelle séquence qui fait suite à la
précédente nous pas à démissionner
pourquoi démissionnerait tél pourquoi
doit écouter bon os on peut contester on
mélange toujours tout on peut contester
la façon dont la politique
internationale a été menée par les
villes de la tunisie
mais bon elle expliqué à l'assemblée
nationale tout à l'heure je n'ai pas de
raison de mettre en doute sa parole que
un ca me l'a proposé depuis tunis delà
de la comprend le même vol que lui ai
bien compris toutes vos camarades
socialistes ont entendu les mêmes
explications mais certains demandent sa
démission l'allemand pas vous n'aurez
pas ce que c'est c'est pas le sujet le
sujet c'est c'est de quelle manière
notre pays peut-il accompagner soutenir
et l'actuel ministre dont défend bien ça
c'est incarne bien la politique
étrangère de la france ne s'était pas
c'est pas moi a décidé du choix du
ministre étranger ça relève du président
la république du premier ministre et
c'est une question je ne dis pas
secondaire mais c'est pas la question
première la question première c'est de
quelle façon accompagne tôt c'est ça
l'essentiel
le peuple tunisien je note que bon mieux
vaut tard que jamais je note que toute
une série d'initiatives sont prises en
ce moment par les états européens et
nous avons par le gouvernement français
à bruxelles pour renforcer
économiquement l'aide de l'union
européenne à la tunisie pour aider à la
préparation des élections
moi ce qui m'importe c'est pas sur un
tel sujet un débat entre x ou y
c'est que les tunisiens conquiert
pacifiquement le droit des niners est ce
qu'on a bien été heurté par les propos
de
michèle alliot marie à l'assemblée
nationale sur son offre sécuritaire à la
tunisie en pleine période des meutes
lancé en effet des propos assez assez
particulier assez étrange
hélas non plus l'idée de sa démission ne
nous était pas venu et pourquoi est ce
que ce sera une autorité suprême qui
doit décider du sort d'un ministre ou
d'un autre ce qui m'intéresse vraiment
profondément c'est le sort du peuple
tunisien et je le laisse entendre vos
amis au ps se trompe de combat alors je
ne dis pas ça ne fait pas polémique qui
n'a pas lieu d'être et la polémique à
leur s impose à noël en verre je
respecte ceux qui réclament sa démission
mais moi je ne réclame rien d'autre que
l'essentiel c'est à dire soutenir les
tunisiens les aider matériellement et
psychologiquement
le reste est secondaire la joute comme
puisqu'on parle du rapport à la tunisie
oui on est partagé par les deux sapins
de vos amis n'ont pas mes amis c'est à
dire je trouve que nous sommes tous nous
sommes la plupart d'entre nous peut
parler de moi c'est un autre cas avant
nous sommes sauf quelques-uns disons
collectivement responsables d'avoir été
d'une complaisance extrême à l'égard de
ces dictatures que comme comme à l'égard
du régime égyptien
le reproche a été fait notamment par
françois fillon à françois mitterrand
aussi au françois mitterrand pas lui non
mais ne mélangeons pas tout on voit la
mi-février pourquoi parce que il faut
aussi une lecture historique des choses
quand françois mitterrand a reçu benali
c'est peut-être quelque temps après
qu'il ait remplacé bourguiba et les
premières années du régime ben ali qui
n'était pas un régime démocratique comme
on le rêve est quand même apporté
satisfaction donner le sentiment qu'il
allait poursuivre pacifiquement l'oeuvre
de bourguiba donc parfaitement admettre
que françois mitterrand les les reçus de
même quand lionel jospin était premier
ministre et qui l'a accueilli moi
j'étais président la commission
d'intrants gère à ce moment là j'ai
boycotté les manifestations officielles
mais vous pouvez le faire j'étais
parlementaire il fait part au
gouvernement et les justin ne pouvait
pas ne pas recevoir benali qui avait été
invité par jacques chirac
le temps a passé et aujourd'hui quand
même lui il est normal qu'une prise de
conscience s'opère à la classe politique
française pour contester ce régime
politique est malheureusement à
l'exception de quelques personnes et une
grande complaisance collective et ça
éviterait une autocritique collective
voilà très bien avec vous la lancez même
si même facile même si le gouvernement
en place évidemment à une responsabilité
plus particulière parce que c'est lui
qui tient les rênes
celui qui a la responsabilité directe
alors est-ce que vous allez regarder
d'un peu plus près la composition de
l'internât socialiste parce que là c'est
un des arguments qu'on entend à droite
jack lang est oui parce que le fameux
parti de ben ali appartenait à
l'internationale socialiste il paraît
même que les chinois en font partie des
choses si c'est ça c'est à revoir si
c'est vraiment le cas
je ne me sens pas membre de
l'internationale socialiste je suis
internationaliste profondément
socialiste et internationaliste mais si
l'agenda is abri des dictateurs c'est
pas mal de l'année dernière question sur
le sujet avant d'évoquer la question du
parti socialiste est ce que vous estimez
que le grand projet de l'union pour la
méditerranée que vous avez défendu
l'idée chère à nicolas sarkozy a
définitivement du plomb dans l aile
annuler la sauver et à françois
mitterrand qui l'avait lancé allah il ya
quelques années mais je l'avais imaginé
autrement cette idée qui est une belle
idée et est aujourd'hui mais qu est ce
qu une erreur
moubarak était associé de le dictateur
celui que vous avez même coup président
et oui même officiellement tous les
couples et dire non je pense qu'on parle
du fond des choses et je m'étais permis
de le dire l'époque l'actuel président
la public
c'était une erreur de voile à vouloir
aller trop vite de concevoir une
organisation entre états il était
préférable de créer une sorte de 2,2
collège international des pays de la
méditerranée en y associant beaucoup
plus les sociétés que les états à
l'elysée on me dit d'accord pense que
l'union de la méditerranée est une bonne
y aller nous allons évoquer votre
engagement et votre travail politique
jack lang pas au service exclusif du
parti socialiste pour lequel vous avez
des baux dur parfois
anne sophie mercier d'ailleurs va nous
rejoindre donc mais d'abord avec thomas
raguet on
fait le point sur vos différentes
activités de la france jack lang a
choisi le costume sur mesure de
missionnaires tous azimuts 2007 nicolas
sarkozy fraîchement élu confie à edouard
balladur la présidence d'une commission
pour moderniser les institutions
jack lang est là aussi sa voix porte
savoie compte au moment du vote allait
même décisif joie - comment je pourrais
moi même participé à l'élaboration de ce
texte
photo t
autre c'est dit et
même une chanson si douce aux oreilles
sarkozienne que jack lang est à nouveau
sollicité février 2009 il est nommé
émissaire spécial du président de la
république à cuba octobre de la même
année une nouvelle mission cette fois en
corée du nord
des missions en pays totalitaires qui
semble lui réussir août 2010 l'onu a des
projets pour lui il est nommé conseiller
juridique auprès de ban ki moon sur les
questions de piraterie au large de la
somalie
mais l'avenir pour jack lang est
peut-être en france peut-être dans le
costume de défenseur des droits
actuellement les bausch les députés ont
eu le bon goût de revenir sur la limite
d'âge à 68 ans qu'ils avaient d'abord
mis en place pour lui barrer la route et
dans tout ça sur le ps jack lang at il
encore des choses à dire
eh bien on va en parler avec nous pour
ce soir collaboratrice des
inrockuptibles du monde magazine c'est à
vous alors jack lang vous avez on l'a on
l'a rappelé la juste une minute vous
avez effectué diverses missions qui ont
vous ont été confiées par chef de l'état
ou qui vous ont été attribués avec son
appui on vous connaît comme le plus
grand ministre de la culture puis
malraux la culture c'est toute votre vie
vous avez lancé un festival qui est
devenu de théâtre il devenu mythique à
nancy voilà la culture si quelqu'un un
cas de la culture c'est vous on peut
tout dire du sarkozysme on peut dire que
c'est une
c'est une énergie on peut dire c'est une
force qui va on peut dire mille choses
mais ce qui sonne vient jamais à
l'esprit que le l'actuel président est
un homme du livre est un fou de culture
c'est qu'est ce qui dans le fond vous
atterri vous attirez vous intérêts dans
le sarkozysme vous passer de deux
missions que j'ai accompli au long de
l'étape
en fait ma transition c'est l'émission
vous avez accompli au nom de l'état
français avec le soutien du chef de
l'état d'où ma question qu'est-ce qui
vous rassurent une pas mais en tout cas
disons maintenant ce qui me passionne
d'abord c'est ce qui est impossible me
passionne c'est si je raconte un peu
même mais c'est pas le sujet enfin peu
plus tard mais l'hiver le rappeur hassan
séjour tout à l'heure
l'émission les actions impossibles
m'intéresse plus que les efforts un peu
tranquille gentil et sert à cuba ou
mission un peu impossible corée du nord
mission impossible
la piraterie maritime lorsque ban ki
moon a proposé des amis charitables ont
du métier complètement cinglé c'est un
sol us et j'ai eu raison de plus je vais
essayer de comprendre je vais 6 2 mais
est ce assez
je suis par ailleurs pas seulement un
homme de culture je suis d'abord même
professeur de droit c'est mon métier
mais sans droit international et je me
suis attelé à cette tâche pendant cinq
mois et je pense que les propositions
que j'ai faites au conseil de sécurité
mardi dernier seront acceptés seront
transformés en résolution qui est qui et
boutiron espérons le la à l'éradication
de la piraterie maritime
quand même répondu à la question on
n'avait pas répondu à la question c'est
est ce qu'il vous plaît c'est celle
émission qu on vous confie yuya horihata
médias dans dans la notion de de
sarkozysme quelque chose qui vous
intéressent qui vous séduit qui vous
attire enfin pour mélanger deux choses
auraient sinon je vais expliquer en quoi
je me sens quand mes convictions
michel raison que je vais vous répondre
quand donc taurin cadres du rpt qui
concerne où l'intérêt supérieur de
l'état ou une organisation
internationale
mes convictions intimes transforme
rejoignent celles de tel ou tel n'y a
aucune raison que je refuse de donner un
coup de main
alors quand ami nicolas sarkozy veut on
peut c'est sa politique n'est pas la
mienne c'est une évidence
je suis de gauche je vis socialisme et
vainqueurs sont autres mais en même
temps j'ai appris de mon maître françois
mitterrand que quand on défend ses idées
on n'a pas nécessairement attaquer les
personnes et je pense que parfois on a
beaucoup trop tendance cet après midi
encore à l'assemblée nationale ou dans
d'autres circonstances
à fin des attaques ad hominem et en quoi
est-ce diminuerez que le reconnaître ses
qualités de d'aider des personnes qui
sont de l'autre côté
oui sarkozy a beaucoup d'énergie
et nous pour aller à la vérité en même
temps il mène une politique sur le plan
fiscal son plan scolaire sur le plan
social n'est pas la meilleure la moutte
voilà alors quand vous parlez de
aujourd'hui de votre action de ce qui
vous fait vient mais en tant j'assume
totalement pleinement plus que jamais la
révision de la constitution qui a été
opéré et à laquelle dont j'ai été l'un
des côtes auraient regardé cette petite
révolution de ce qu'on appelle la
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité que mitterrand
souhaité badinter aussi et qui a été
réalisé dans la révision
constitutionnelle et qui fait que toute
une série de lois illégales ont été
censurés par le conseil pour monsieur et
bienheureux n'y aurait plus que ce
changement
je serais très heureux d'avoir participé
à ce travail collectif et de l'avoir
votée et je regrette que mes amis
socialistes n'est pas voter eux mêmes
c'est ribéry la critique cette révision
à nouveau il s'empare de ce sujet vous
le savez au parti socialiste et certains
disent qu'il faut corriger la boulimie
de pouvoir du chef de l'état
corriger cela par une nouvelle réforme
par exemple ne plus permettre au chef de
l'état de s'exprimer devant le congrès
est-ce que là vous estimez qu'il ya des
corrections apportées je n'ai pas lu le
texte inédit romaine excusez moi si je
n'ai pas lu le texte on veut pas partir
évaluation mais si si véritablement la
proposition de réforme consiste pour
pour mes amis à interdire au chef de
l'état de venir à l'assemblée qu'elle
profondes réformes c'est une erreur de
dire moi je suis pour que le chef de
l'état viennent à l'assemblée
il est élu il doit ainsi la sim c'est ça
qui souhaitent ne m'apportait pour la
question même qu'il participe à un débat
je ne comprends même pas pourquoi ce
pauvre où nicolas sarkozy n'a pas dévoyé
cette réforme et il n'est pas nécessaire
de renforcer les contre-pouvoirs l'hôtel
qu'on dit non non non non non je mens je
rêve d'une profonde une nouvelle
profonde rénovation des institutions pas
se contenter d'une réformette des pas
ont été accomplis par jour c'est en
allant dans ce sens disons le mandat
cinq ans et en produisant la parité
hommes-femmes par nicolas sarkozy à
travers toute une série de choses
concernant notamment le le le contrôle
du conseil constitutionnel le fait qu'il
ne préside plus le conseil de la
magistrature 20 d'autres de réformes
pas suffisant c'est un pas en avant moi
je considère que vous en êtes démocrates
ont engrangé tout une mesure qui vous
paraît importante d'entre vous situeriez
quoi j'espère que ça figure dans le
projet socialiste
un vrai parlement devrait commission
denquête que l'ordre dès que l'ordre du
jour soit fixée par le seul parlement
mais voilà de vraies réformes
je ne sais pas si c'est ce sont ces
réformes qui seront proposés moi c'est
pas une question de numérotation la
république c'est grotesque
le carillon la saga le public mais un
rénovant la transforme aulas pour
l'instant ça a été la politique des
petits pas que j'ai soutenu et mais
j'espère que demain s'il y avait un
changement politique jusqu'à la
politique des grands pas on va juste un
mot sur sur les primaires socialistes
chaque langue vous avez vous avez eu sur
ce processus des primaires des mots durs
ça avec vos amis ça vous arrive tout de
même assez fréquemment vous allez parler
d'eux depuis longtemps son cas cela non
vous avez parlé de pétaudière ysern
hippodrome sk pas aussi dans le
processus des primaires une notion de
modernité que vous voulez pas voir non
ces vapeurs moi je suis le premier avec
racks amène le maire de dijon avoir
procréé primaire il ya huit ans dont je
l'espère et je suis pour
et on met sur le dos des primaires
quelque chose qui n'a rien n'arrête les
primaires primaires ou pas il y aurait
ce phénomène que nous vivons en ce
moment de compétition entre candidats et
recoins et ça normal bon alors parfois
ça prend un tour un peu pour hier six
jeux politiques syrie oui peut-être
la difficulté d'émergence d'un leader
politique un incontesté mais je pense
que les choses se décanteront c'est à
dire c'est à dire allez faut nous en
dire plus là parce que je crois que vous
avez rencontré dominique strauss kahn
récemment à washington alors que le
monde ça va se décanter récente bientôt
ça je ne sais pas mal d'informations
j'ai rencontré en effet dominé strauss
kahn qui est un collègue section
professeur dans la même université à
nancy pour longtemps malheureusement
c'est un homme intelligent c'est un type
qui m'ont ses grandes capacités à la
tête du fmi il à laquelle il aurait la
carrure
deux chefs d'état s'étaient contestable
la décision lui appartient je ne
parlerais changé je vais pas parler en
son nom
j'ai pas mal roulé rendez vous avait
sondé ses intentions bon ça relève d'une
conversation n'avons vous êtes rassurés
vous êtes sortis rassurés
je rappelle en face aux religions
personnel très profondément de personnel
et comment est-ce que comment est ce que
vous réagissez à jean françois copé qui
dit à propos de nuit j'en ai marre de ce
type en temps dit il c'est tout surtout
cette statue du commandeur c'est oracle
je dirais un mouvement de mauvaise
humeur
alors une question devrait faire
attention chacun d'entre nous ça
m'arrive aussi de sa veine glissade qui
conduisent à dire des choses un peu
désagréable à l'égard de tel ou tel
camarades ou concurrents je reviens à
votre prise de distance par rapport aux
tests et à regarder tout vrai que je
n'ai pas les arrêts écoutez je sais
c'est pas vrai c'est moi qui suis en
conformité excusez moi en conformité
avec les grandes idées progressistes
c'est moi qui suis en conformité avec
les grandes idées démocratiques et
lorsque j'ai soutenu le braiment train
de dire que vous n'êtes pas cessé d'être
soutenu le président de la république
dans sa volonté de réforme de la
constitution
c'était en harmonie avec ce que nous
avons nous même défendu sous le la
présidence de jospin lorsqu'il était
premier secrétaire
sous la présidence de françois
mitterrand la série parle mais je ne
comprends pas qu'on puisse changer
d'avis et d'opinions selon koné tôt au
gouvernement ou dans l'opposition les
convictions d'abord les convictions des
morts les petits calculs politiques
ensuite les notions très important de
prix socialistes qui la lutte contre le
cumul des mandats ils vous auriez pu
aussi à son en profiter pour pour en
parler pour porter sa soeur mais elle a
fait durer dans les propositions de la
commission balladur qui a été si
critiquées par saft un temps il c'était
une des propositions qui ont voté à
l'unanimité aux salles commission
présidée par edouard balladur
elle n'a pas été retenue par le
gouvernement je le regrette et je pense
est en effet dans les courses qu'on
m'annonce être le futur projet social
c'est une bonne mesure de démocratie
donne dernière question est ce que vous
pensez que le ps est prêt pour le
pouvoir en 2012 ya alors il ya toute une
nuit à du buzz sur internet sur une
déclaration que vous auriez fait
peut-être pouvoir vous en expliquer sur
internet on voit une vidéo où ont
semble-t-il je dis bien semble-t-il je
le prend avec des pincettes
en vous écoutant on entendrait si on
gagne en 2012 c'est la cata alors est-ce
que je d'abord est ce que vous l'avez
vraiment dit et si vous l'avez dit
qu'est ce que qu'est ce que vous dites
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire vraiment
je me souviens pas très bien parce que
la mémoire de rayon près en présence de
madame royal je m'éclate désirs d'avenir
essayer d'interpréter des propres propos
si tu devais tenue en effet si
aujourd'hui à l'instant aujourd'hui nous
étions en responsabilité bon ça serait
pas très brillant parce que pour le
moment le projet est en est là bas